ce
[Musique]
pierre-jean bâti j'ai 27 ans je suis
président des jeunes démocrates depuis
un an je suis engagé au mouvement
démocrate depuis déjà une dizaine
d'années et j'étais candidat lors des
dernières élections européennes
les jeunes démocrates c'est un grand
mouvement de politique pour les jeunes
de notre pays c'est un des deux
mouvements qui structure la majorité
présidentielle et nous nous rassemblons
les jeunes qui sont passionnés qui
veulent défendre l'humanisme en
politique l'écologie le réformisme
l'europe sont des valeurs ce sont des
thèmes qui nous sont chères et qu'on
insulte à la fois au niveau local dans
nos territoires mais aussi au niveau
national en réfléchissant sur les grands
enjeux du monde contemporain sur les
sujets d'actualité
on invite les jeunes à s'investir à nos
côtés à réfléchir à nos côtés parce que
ce monde qu'on est en train de
construire
et bien c'est important qu'on s'y engage
dès aujourd'hui c'est important d'être
jeune en politique parce qu'il faut que
la politique ressemble la société
d'aujourd'hui
c'est important que toutes les
générations s'impliquent on a une
responsabilité particulière évidemment
quand on est jeune puisque on va vivre
dans le monde
de demain et donc s'impliquer dès
aujourd'hui c'est évidemment important
c'est évidemment nécessaire le bric site
n'aurait pas eu lieu si la jeunesse
anglais s'étaient mobilisés à la hauteur
des autres générations
ça montre bien qu'une jeunesse
silencieuse c'est un handicap pour un
pays
[Musique]